Alright, so to make this work, we're going to need to build on this
idea of a joint distribution. It's not going to be obvious right away what
this has to do with machine learning, at all. But, I, it's going to
connect. So, just bear with me for a little bit. Alright, so to talk
about this concept, what we're going to do is look at an example. And
the example that I think might work, that would be nice and simple, is
the notion of storm and lightning. So, here's a little picture of storm
and lightning. And what we're going to do is say, let's say, on a random
day, at 2 PM. You look outside. And, what I want you to do
is say, what fraction of the time,
is, is each of these different possible combination
of things happening? So, for example, what's
the probability that you look out and
there's a storm and there's lightning at the same time? So, what do you think?
>> On a random day?
>> Yeah, random day at 2 PM. And we
can be in Atlanta since that's what you're familiar with.
>> Is it summer? Because that happens more often in the summer.
>> Sure, let's say summer.
>> It's fairly high at 2 PM. Let's say it happens a quarter of the time.
>> Wow, that's a rainy summer.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Alright. Now, that's not the only possibility though. It
could also be that there's a storm but no lightning.
>> Right. That happens more often at 2 PM
in the summer in Atlanta. Let's say it's mm, .4.
>> Wow. Alright. Now what's the probability that you look
at the window and there's no storm but there is lightning.
>> Maybe 5%.
>> And what's the probability that you look out and
there's, you know, it's nice clear there's no storm no lightning.
>> Coincidentally I picked numbers that made it easier
for me to subtract from one. So, it's 0.3.
>> [LAUGH] Right and so these, there's only, these are the only four
possibilities. We're saying. And they, so they have to add up to 100%. And
so I, yeah it had to be 30 at this point. So, it's
actually more likely that there's a storm than not, according to what you said.
>> It's Atlanta
in the summer at 2 PM.
>> There you go. Alright. So, this is a
joint distribution. And now we can actually ask various
kinds of questions about this. Oh, you know what
would be a good form for asking a question.
>> I don't know. I'm looking at you quizzically.
>> Nice. Using the fact that we are in
the same place. We are going to do a quiz.